I see walls there's a surface that
absorbs the changes that have been in
every city every day at every hour I see
walls as an archaeology sees something
that they can study and they can reflect
on macau is very interesting because you
have a lot of different architecture a
lot of the contrast between the old and
the new when I carve a wall here I can
see history I can see layers I can see
time and that's why it really inspires
me
[Music]
my name is alexandre pato I'm also known
as veal and I'm from Portugal I
basically create an artwork by carving
and destroying the surface of the walls
I started when I was 13 years old doing
mostly graffiti and illegal walls but
the work evolved to what I do today
which is much different from graffiti
and one day I arrived to a conclusion
that why am i adding to or why why
should I do not work with what's already
there
I usually go and I film the city a
photograph I draw a lot and I gathered
several portraits of different people
and then I go to the walls I first
painted with graffiti and sketch the
different depths and then that allows me
to go to the wall and then carve the
answer I never know how the work is
going to look because each wall has
their own way of behaving so in the end
I don't know the result and I like that
I like the fact that the wall actually
detects the final result of the artwork
Macau is a very particular place is
place where have both murals graffiti
advertising and this it's something that
inspires me a lot because the work tries
to work with what's invisible what's
inside the walls of the city
I feel very happy when people have a
good reaction is very pleasing to hear
different opinions and interpretations
of your work people see their own ideas
concepts and feelings I think that's
very interesting for me
this is always what prize before
you